alors il semblerait effectivement qu'il
y ait quelqu'un territorial à signaler
pour la journée d'hier mais vraiment
très petit les Ukrainiens ont consolidé
il semblerait leur gains dans les quatre
villages au sud de Velika novocycle le
village le plus possible parmi ces
quatre étaient le cibles d'une
contre-offensive russe les Russes
essayer de reprendre
Ukrainiens le village très rapidement
après que les Ukrainiens avaient libéré
ce village mais selon des images
satellites il semblerait que ma carieka
disent les analystes et bel et bien aux
mains des Ukrainiens qui n'ont pas
toutefois vraiment percés les plus
grandes lignes de défense russe pour le
moment je pense et c'est la vie des
experts plutôt que ce que nous voyons en
ce moment ce sont un peu des des
opérations de sondages pour voir où
est-ce que il peut y avoir une brèche à
faire dans les lignes de défense russe
les plus grandes lignes de défense les
tranchées très important qu'ils ont
pendant des mois et des mois à
construire ces lignes de défense je vous
rappelle sont plus au sud des endroits
que les Ukrainiens jusqu'où les
Ukrainiens sont réussis à aller jusqu'à
présent mais ce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est que cette guerre et cette
contre-offensive c'est aussi les frappes
à longue distance derrière les lignes
russes tous les jours il y a des frappes
ukrainiennes on se servant des
Américains par exemple les Storm Shadows
britanniques les roquettes de haute
précision et de l'ont porter même sur
des endroits comme le port de bergence
ou melithopole une grosse ville dans la
partie de la région des aporisa occupé
par les Russes les Ukrainiens disent
ciblés des bases du matériel militaire
parfois et c'est parfois aussi sur les
télégrammes de Russes qui sont indignés
contre leur commandant il y a des
informations comme quoi un très grand
nombre de combattants russes auraient
été tués par ces frappes mais dans le
brouillard de la guerre c'est difficile
de vraiment avoir une confirmation
sur de ces informations
Gulliver vous vous trouvez asaporigia
nous disions le patron de l'IA doit
visiter sans doute aujourd'hui la
centrale nucléaire de zapporja quelles
sont les dernières informations dont
vous disposez
alors le problème c'est que la centrale
des aporisa elle est à 55 km dans cette
direction là mais plus de 100 km en fait
par la route 55
à vol d'oiseau et la route traverse la
ligne de front qui est une ligne de
front active pour le moment il
semblerait que les conditions de
sécurité ne sont pas réunies pour
effectuer cette visite et les Ukrainiens
ne sont même pas allés jusqu'à dire que
cela aura lieu aujourd'hui ils ont dit
ils espèrent mais plutôt dans les
prochains jours ça c'est ce qu'a dit le
ministre de l'énergie mais côté russe
ils assurent que c'est aujourd'hui que
la visite aura lieu alors on va
peut-être voir s'il va réussir à
traverser cette ligne aujourd'hui
Raphaël grossit bien sûr et inquiété par
le trépan niveau d'eau dont la Nièvre
derrière moi vous le voyez la centrale a
besoin de cette eau pour ces systèmes de
refroidissement même si elle ne génère
pas d'électricité en ce moment donc n'a
pas un très grand besoin en termes de
refroidissement mais Rafael grossi c'est
aussi dit très inquiet tout simplement
par le fait que normalement la
contrefossive ukrainienne cible aussi la
centrale qui est occupée par les Russes
ils ont bien l'intention de libérer ces
territoires là aussi ce qui bien sûr
porte un grand danger en termes de
sécurité sur cette installation
nucléaire merci